Oh
yes well they're there two ways two ways
in which our work I could inform
clinical treatment in the area of early
diagnosis if there is a child and it's
developing it's giving off developmental
clues there might be something wrong if
we had a list of the kind of genetic
lesions that we could screen for we
might be able to determine early on that
this child is going to develop a a form
of autism and if it's correct more most
disorders are correctable to the extent
that they are correctable are more
correctable early than late when we know
how to correct or or treat we'll be able
to start that sooner so early diagnosis
is going to be important for any
disorder that's one way another way is
children with a particular genetic
abnormality that is those children that
share genetic or abnormality may have
one particular way of treating them
that's different than children have a
different abnormality we will only learn
about that once we can separate these
children according to their genetic
abnormalities that's going to take many
many years the third way is that in in
some cases we will be identifying genes
who by their very nature tell us this is
a correctable untreatable syndrome for
example we find a gene that's involved
in metabolized metabolism is this child
is is perhaps got really storage
disorder some time by altering the diet
in those cases you might be able to
treat the child but unfortunately we
don't yet know the identities of the
autism genes we have regions um and
there's a huge effort underway i would i
would say in particular by by doing very
exhaustive sequence comparisons of
children to their parents we will
identify the actual culprit genes um and
that will take us two to four years and
there may be
unfortunately i'm estimating around 400
such genes that each one of which can
cause autism but when we have those
jeans we see what they do we can see
what pathways they're interacting with
some of those will suggest immediately
treatments that can be that can be
tested and we'll be able to make animal
models and test drugs and animals to
correct these things so in general the
way to understand the disorder is to
understand its causes and then address
those causes in the case of autism most
most people would agree i think most
scientists would agree the causes are
genetic and we have a pathway to
discover the genes so it will be easier
to diagnose are classified by diagnosis
into behavioral or even drug treatments
and discover new drug treatments